[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris directeur le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec les gens vont manger un autre
combat ma vie qui est celui de la
sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet de
loi qui vise à mettre en place des
thèses attitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission n'est décrypteront
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 20 avril
chauffeur routier caissier éboueurs de
plus de 55 ans la vaccination élargit
encore à partir de samedi tout comme
pour l'astra zeneca l'agencé européenne
du médicament juge que les caillots
sanguins devraient être ajoutées aux
effets secondaires ardue johnson and
johnson
la perspective d'une réouverture
progressive me mets sur toutes les
lèvres
olivier verront se dit favorable 1
déconfinement territorialisées le
ministre de la santé qui parle d'une
décrue fragile dans le pays
[Musique]
outre-rhin armin l'arche est plébiscité
par son parti pour être le successeur
d'un gala merkel après une semaine de
duel fratricide avec marcus odeurs la cd
ou s'est prononcé en faveur de la
candidature du dirigeant conservateur à
plus de 77% à cinq mois des légers des
élections législatives du 26 septembre
la droite allemande a donc enfin son
candidat est la france souligne
l'importance d'une transition pacifique
au tchad
réactions après la mort du président
idriss déby il a succombé à des
blessures reçues au front ce week end
il venait d'être réélu pour un sixième
mandat le pouvoir était confié à un
conseil militaire dirigée par l'un des
fils qui vient de nommer 15 généraux
[Musique]
au début de la deuxième semaine de
vacances unifier la situation sanitaire
en france est toujours fragile avec un
niveau encore loin du pic de la première
vague en avril 2020 mais tout de même un
plateau haut
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite katia pique nique en
direct de l'hôpital européen
georges-pompidou bonsoir katia sur le
front de l'épidémie
où en sommes nous oui bien stéphanie
nous venons d'apprendre qu'une nouvelle
catégorie de salariés prioritaires
pourra se faire vacciner dès samedi
la liste a été dressée par elisabeth
bornes la ministre du travail en
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
alors de qui s'agit-il et bien d'une
vingtaine de métiers comme les
conducteurs de bus les caissiers
caissières de supermarché les éboueurs
les employés des abattoirs ou encore des
pompes funèbres
en tout 400 mille personnes de plus de
55 ans
alors katia attend des nouvelles au
niveau des vaccins oui absolument tout
le monde avait les yeux rivés
aujourd'hui sur le verdict de l'agencé
européenne du médicament au sujet du
vaccin johnson & johnson et bien elle a
tranché elle a estimé que la balance
bénéfice risque était en faveur de ce
vaccin
il conviendra juste de noter que
les les effets secondaires très rare
pouvait être donc les fameux caillot
sanguin pour cette raison les autorités
sanitaires américaines avaient
interrompu l'utilisation de ce vaccin
l'histoire d'y voir plus clair après des
incidents justement très grave
alors cette décision de l'agencé
d'autant plus attendu que la france
compte bien sûr le johnson & johnson est
également sur d'autres vaccins tels que
l'astra zeneca le johnsen qui serait
indispensable pour atteindre les
objectifs de vaccination du gouvernement
des objectifs qui sont fixés à 20
millions de personnes ayant reçu au
moins la première dose à la mi mai alors
pour le moment il faut dire que l'asra
zeneca n'est réservée qu'aux plus de 55
ans il ya eu des polémiques et des
effets secondaires importants alors les
aspirants aux vaccins n'ont pas très
envie d'utiliser cette astra zeneca et
le vaccin ne jouit pas d'une très grande
popularité auprès d'eux à catllar à ce
qu'on en sait plus sur le fameux
déconfinement oui stéphanie en effet
olivier ferrand a annoncé que l'épidémie
décroît sais mais bon il y a toujours
33000 contamination par jour donc pas de
quoi pavoiser mais il a évoqué l'idée
d'un déconfinement territoire par
territoire sans se protégeant se
prononcer davantage mais la levée des
restrictions sera effectuée en fonction
de la situation épidémique et du taux de
remplissage des hôpitaux
quant aux écoles du premier degré et
bien elles rouvriront le 26 avril comme
prévu pour les collèges et lycées il
faudra attendre le 3 mai mais cette fois
ci il ne sera pas question de tenir
compte des indicateurs sanitaires
vous imaginez que ça suscite
l'inquiétude des parents qui avaient vu
les écoles fermées en cascade avant le
confinement ils redoutent les
conséquences de la réouverture car les
établissements scolaires sont un lieu
majeur de contamination mais
curieusement il n'y a pas eu de nouveaux
protocoles sanitaires communiquer à ses
parents très inquiet on est merci katia
technique en direct de l'hôpital
européen georges pompidou et une
réouverture progressive à partir de là
me mais est ce encore possible alors que
la situation sanitaire n'est pas connu
de franche amélioration si oui la
décision ne se rappelle pas avant tout
politique place à notre décryptage avec
nos invités et avec nous pour en parler
laurent alexandre essayiste et
chirurgien jean philippe du coin clément
maire udi de mennecy vice-président du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
sur l'antenne d'arte et france un plus
de 30 mille cas quotidiens donc un de
corona bio c'est environ 300 morts par
jour en france est ce qu'on appelle un
plateau haut il n'y at il vraiment une
décroissance de l'épidémie depuis le
début de la campagne de vaccination
comme le dit le ministre de la santé
laurent alexandre on a une baisse de la
mortalité chez les plus âgés et
notamment dans les ehpad
mais on n'a pas d'amélioration sur le
front des réanimations parce que les
personnes âgées en ehpad n'ont jamais
été envoyé en réanimation donc
l'augmentation de la vaccination dans
les ehpad ne diminue pas la pression sur
les réanimations ça diminue juste le
nombre total de morts c'est à dire des
morts hospitalière plus les morts en
ehpad
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation difficile où le faible taux de
vaccination des gens âgés qui ne sont
pas en ehpad ne permet pas encore
d'avoir une amélioration dans le taux de
malades en réanimation et de malades
graves
jean jean fini par demander quoi
clémence est vrai que les avis sont son
cadre contradictoires sur un progrès ou
non clairement at on les moyens d'une
réouverture début mai dans ces
conditions je le rappelle un peu de
30000 quatre quotidiens par jour 300
morts par jour en france les trois morts
par jour en france et chaque jour un
boeing l'un d'airbus qui se crashe après
la réalité après un an après un
troisième confinement c'est qu'il ya une
attente extrêmement forte
beaucoup beaucoup de français pour
pouvoir recommencer à avoir une vie
intégralement normal mais à pouvoir
avoir quelques activités culturelles
quelques activités sociales c'est le
fait que l'angleterre ou l'espagne les
aubert des terrasses qu' un certain
nombre d'annoncés ont été entamées par
le pouvoir par le gouvernement est donc
cet espoir et cette attente
elle tient à beaucoup beaucoup de gens
après la réalité la pression spontanée
elle reste très élevé j'étais un
vendredi dorment sur les visites des
réanimations d'un hôpital en
seine-et-marne où effectivement la
baisse du taux d'incidence ne se traduit
pas encore aujourd'hui en termes de
moins de deux passions ou moins de
malades et avec pour le coup plutôt une
diminution des moyenne d'âge des
patients hospitalisés
aurait elle une chic alors vous venez de
le dire dans certains endroits du monde
la vie reprend entre elles et l'épidémie
à une levée progressive des mesures
sanitaires la californie israël le
royaume uni on va regarder ces images
qui nous font un petit peu de mal faut
bien le dire
largement diffusée déjà celle de boris
johnson qui me nargue buvant une bière
dans le centre du du pays
hier laurent alexandre clairement est ce
qu'on peut en espérer d'eux mêmes dans
un avenir plus ou moins proche
selon vous ben ça va être un petit peu
difficile parce que il vous a pas
échappé que la france aura le taux de
vaccination anglais dans trois mois
la france a trois mois de retard sur
l'angleterre en matière de taux de
vaccination là deux mois de retard sur
les etats-unis
elle a six mois de retard sur israël
dire que la france aura le taux de
vaccination d'aujourd'hui en israël en
septembre
c'est à dire six mois de retard donc le
de confinement va se faire
progressivement pour des raisons
politiques
nous sommes à un an de la présidentielle
l'échec de la politique vaccinale du
gouvernement qui est lié aux mauvaises
négociations européennes sur les vaccins
conduit à un énorme retard de l'union
européenne dont la france mais ça n'est
plus potable
les images de tous les pays qui des
conflits d'aujourd'hui met une
sur le président de la république énorme
compte tenu de la proximité des échecs
des échéances pas tellement les
régionales les élections locales qui
sont perdus pour le pouvoir mais la
présidentielle maintient la campagne
pour les présidentielles va commencer
dans six mois
le président ne peut pas maintenir une
pression aussi forte
au moment où tout le monde des consignes
se dire que de boris johnson n'a eu à
juste titre le président de la
république française
et ces images vont faire de plus en plus
de mal politiquement si l'on est sinon
le réseau n'est que d'un point de vue
épidémiologique il faudrait maintenir un
confinement encore plus fort pendant un
deux mois mais ce n'est pas socialement
possible les français ne le supporterait
pas et ce n'est pas politiquement
possible de corelli t on va prendre un
risque médical et des mieux logique
parce que la situation politico-sociale
ne permet pas de le continuer à confiner
mais notre immense retard vaccinale
justifierait on retarde le déconfinement
mais en tant que citoyen et je ne le
souhaite pas aujourd'hui parce que les
effets secondaires même médicaux de ces
confinement à répétition sont maintenant
trop élevé il faudra réfléchir aux
raisons qui ont fait que que la france
et l'europe sont tellement tromper dans
la négociation des contrats de vaccins
et ont pris des mois et des mois de
retard sur les autres pays développés
mais on ne pleure pas sur du lait
renversé
aujourd'hui il faut contester là il faut
constater la réalité on va devoir et
ouvrir sur un plateau haut parce qu'il
n'est plus possible de maintenir les
gens fous bloch plus longtemps ça fait
six mois qu'ils restaurent long terme et
ça fait six mois que la culture est
complètement bloquée sur n'est plus
tenable
jean-philippe du coin clément en
substance que nous dit à laurent
alexandre c'est que la décision sera
forcément politique et pas dictée par
voilà d'aider des vraies raisons
sanitaires
ça veut dire qu'on va choisir le cynisme
qu'on va choisir finalement de sacrifier
des gens il y aura des gens qui vont
mourir parce que
là il faudra des confiné pour des
raisons politiques mais toute décision
est ferme mais poli qui le fait de
confier le premier le deuxième de 3e
confirmant le fait de ne pas confier
quand on pensait qu'on allait sur le
même trajectoire que l'espagne de
l'angleterre fin janvier février ou
aujourd'hui de les confier tout ça n'est
que des choix politiques
le choix politique c'est l'arbitrage
entre eux la demande sanitaire la
demande économique la demande sociale
donc du foie est par nature purement
politique au sens noble du terme
d'ailleurs ce après la réalité aussi
c'est que maintenir le confinement tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui ça va devenir
extrêmement difficile tenir là
confinement en avril mai juin pour les
journées rallongent il fait beau c'est
beaucoup plus difficile que le faire en
hiver en janvier et février quand il
fait nuit à 18h30
c'est aussi une réalité tenir un
confinement après un an
c'est plus difficile peut le tenir après
le 9 ou 10 mois dont il ya aussi cette
réalité avec qui existe et moi je met
quand même extrêmement regarde quand on
parle lui fait de dire on ré ouvre est
ce qu'il y aura une explosion à ce qu'il
y aura des morts supplémentaires
qu'elles sont et aujourd'hui la réalité
c'est que personne ne le connaît le
bilan sanitaire sur le nom test le
certaines pathologies non prise en
charge des trois confinement successives
on a eu combien de personnes ne se font
plus dépisté ne se font pas testé
combien pathologie du fait des
annulations des reports d'opérations qui
sont faites sur les hôpitaux ne sont pas
prises à temps vont écrire il est fait
le plus mal
donc la réalité c'est que le confinement
génère un certain nombre de protections
par rapport à la copie
mais y compris d'après lui si les tarifs
aux autres problèmes induits et la
réalité c'est que la globalité la photo
global de la facture des choix
politiques
en effet depuis un an encore une fois
toucherait les politiques on l'a
mesurera que dans quelques mois ou dans
quelques années alors il ya des gens qui
sont encore plus pessimistes ans c'est
le cas du président du conseil
scientifique jean françois delfraissy
pour lui la sortie de crise
non pas pour demain et côté on aura
probablement à l'automne de nouveau une
circulation virale importante mais on
aura une large population vaccinée je
vois une sortie de crise définitive plus
tôt en 2022 en 2022 laurent alexandre je
m'adresse aux au docteur que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes aussi pessimiste
que jean françois delfraissy aujourd'hui
alors en temps en temps que médecin je
suis aujourd'hui convaincu que mes
collègues et moi nous devons tous faire
une crise d'humilité nous nous sommes
beaucoup trompé sur nos pronostics et
épidémiologiques donc faire des
pronostics à 6 - hors j'incite tous mes
collègues a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de prudence et je ne suis pas ce que je
fait une bonne politique de paniquer les
gens aujourd'hui je pense vraiment et
les derniers chiffres sur l'impact des
campagnes vaccinales dans les pays qui
ont vacciné vite sont très bons et nous
incite à l'optimiste à l'optimisme je
pense qu'il faut vacciner plus vite mais
en france on vaccine encore lentement
avant-hier on a vacciné 82 mille
personnes c'est-à-dire 0 12% de la
population mais états unis l'angleterre
vaccine autour de 1 % par jour
israël vacciner 5% parcours donc la
vaccination escargots continue en france
je pense qu'au lieu de de paniquer les
français comme le fait d' el fassi il
faudrait qu'on aille plus vite sur la
vaccination et qu'on rattrape les pays
qui ont vacciné vite parce que c'est
notre seule chance de nous en sortir
et personnellement je pense que si on
vaccine plus vite on devrait avoir un
pic d'automne beaucoup plus faible à
moins malheureusement qu'il y ait de
nouveaux variants qui deviennent
résistants au vaccin mais pour l'instant
en réalité les variants que l'on voit
aujourd'hui reste sensible fortement ou
assez fortement au vaccin notamment où
va créer un arn messagers alors
alexandre sauf que la vaccination
on accéléré ça semble être un voeu pieux
aujourd'hui regardez cette image qui
fait mal hein illustration dans le
centre de paris c'était dimanche
ce centre tout simplement vite avec des
pompiers qui attendent sagement dehors
voilà c'est pas la foule des grands
jours on précise que ce centre
dispensé de l'astra est née card
malheureusement dont beaucoup se méfient
que vous inspirent ces images ans
philippe dugoin clément alors que
laurent alexandre vient de nous le
rappeler il faut absolument vacciner
vacciner vacciner on paye succession
d'erreurs au castel de communication
enfin vous prendre l'exemple encore une
fois l'angleterre en angleterre à
vacciner massivement au astrazeneca
le nombre de cas graves d'accidents et
au astrazeneca mais s'approche de la
chance la malchance de gagner au loto
la réalité c'est que en ayant un
ministre comme lille dimanche soir il ya
trois semaines et a aucun problème sur
le astra l'elysée kg lundi revient
dessus quand on suspend pendant quelques
jours sur quelque chose où les peurs et
est très restreinte sur le vexin on a
recréé eu peur et on a donné
l'impression que tu avais le médecin du
riche max un duo qui avait le vaccin de
l'automne et on a collé cette étiquette
est sur leurs traces et nectars et ce
qui est absolument terrible c'est qu'à
monter en charge de la vaccination elle
ne peut se faire qu'avec l'ensemble des
bassins 6e astra le johnson sur lequel
on est en train de créer la même peur ou
la même polémique si on est uniquement
sur le cuiseur ça va prendre beaucoup
plus de temps
donc je crois ce qui est urgent
aujourd'hui pour éviter d'avoir un site
une situation de pénurie qui dure est-ce
qu'on est plutôt en train de commencer
en sortir sur le nombre de vaccins qui
arrive c'est de ré expliquer ces deux
reçu ces deux rassurés les gens travail
qui a été fait en décembre janvier
février et pour tous les vaccins on est
obligés de leur faire vainquant sur
l'estrade du fait d'erreurs de
communication
laurent alexandre votre collègue argent
jean philippe dugoin clément du jour là
la cité se johnson & johnson qui a eu le
feu vert aujourd'hui de l'agencé
européenne du médicament
ça va être voilà
le même scénario que pour astrazeneca
c'est à dire un échec cuisant annoncé
parce qu'on fait des choses moins bien
est ce qu'il n'ya que ça où les français
sont particulièrement réticent et
sceptique par rapport aux britanniques
on paye l'erreur de communication du
président de la république depuis
décembre le 4 décembre dernier
macron donne une interview à brut et il
explique les dangers de la vaccination
devant le journaliste de brut
c'est l'époque où en angleterre on se
lance dans la vaccination pour aller
très vite
quelques semaines plus tard la reine
d'angleterre et boris johnson sont
vaccinés publiquement pour donner
confiance comme le roi du maroc s'est
fait vacciner publiquement olivier v au
fond jean castex au ciel très
tardivement et uniquement quand il ya eu
la catastrophe avec les gens qui
refusait de se faire vacciner
donc la communication en france a été
catastrophique
saint décembre fischer a tenu des
discours sur les dangers
le monsieur vaccination du gouvernement
a tenu des discours complètement
pessimiste incroyablement inquiétant sur
la vaccination
même moi qui suis un pro vaccin
absolument acharnée j'aurai fini par
être paniqué par fisher fin fin décembre
notamment dans ses interviews sur europe
1 donc la communication du gouvernement
a été une communication
contre-productive l'état à paniquer les
français et puis l'interruption de
l'astra zi cas pendant quatre jours a
été absolument désastreuse
on a beaucoup beaucoup moins de chance
de faire un caillou sous astra que
d'être foudroyée tête piquée par une de
mourir d'une piqûre de vipère en france
le dos 2-2 de caillou est beaucoup plus
faible que chez les fumeurs il est
beaucoup plus faible que chez les femmes
qui prennent la pilule
la probabilité de faire un caillou elle
est de l'ordre de 2 cas par million au
maximum c'est un taux absolument
extrêmement faible le risque de mourir
quand on n'est pas vacciner beaucoup
plus important moi personnellement étant
médecin j'ai été vacciné très tôt donc
au freezer
mais j'ai prescrit un astrazeneca ma
femme et ma femme a été une maxi d hier
c'est des cas et je n'ai pas le moindre
la moindre inquiétude sur le risque
elle prendrait un risque beaucoup plus
important à ne pas être vaccinés donc
j'incite vos auditeurs à se précipiter
pour aller se faire vacciner par l'astra
et par le johnsen plutôt que de finir en
réanimation dans un mois oui et face à
la peur de certains français concernant
ce vaccin sera zeneca vous le maire
de même si en ile de france dénonce
aussi le gâchis des vaccins en raison du
manque de civisme de personnes qui
n'honorent pas leurs rendez vous auquel
est la situation sur place parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a tous autour de nous
des personnes qui ont peut-être eu la
chance de se faire vacciner en fin de
journée quand il avait l'idée
éventuellement d'aller dans les stands
mais beaucoup de personnes qui prennent
rendez vous sur d'octo libre d'octo
libre ne vont tout simplement pas honoré
leur rendez vous ça existe ça aussi sur
le terrain monsieur le maire oui alors
la réalité c'est que d'un centre de
vaccination à l'autre on s'organise pour
éviter erdre des doses sur le centre si
on est comme une envie aux diffuseurs
dont il ya moins de refus sur le à traou
effectivement manquerait ce phénomène de
reflux si absolument fou quand on voit
la tante de beaucoup de gens et quand on
a des gens qui ne prennent pas et lien
avec les médecins avec les internes et
qui sont sur place ont ré appel en fin
de journée des personnes à des des gens
dont on sait qu'ils sont en attentes etc
on rappelle au souvenir dans une demi
heure trois quart d'heure où vous
renvoie sans vaccination et on a la même
chose qui se fait sur les pharmaciens
qui distance du astrazeneca puisque pour
le coup eux ont le droit de vacciner en
astrazeneca ont leur terme et pour
faciliter les choses de son groupe et
sur une salle communale plutôt que de
faire au cou le coup dans leur pharmacie
et on est l'exemple dimanche dernier il
restait trois doses en fin de journée et
on a réussi à trouver entre les
pharmaciens et les les personnes winzip
au des gens correspondent au fait qu'ils
étaient très sexy neige mais ça
nécessite d'avoir beaucoup de souplesse
et ça nécessite vraiment j'insiste sur
le problème du astra qui refusait à
beaucoup de gens l'ul part de rassurer
de d'essayer d'éteindre des peurs et je
pense aussi pour la question du à frasne
d'ouvrir plus largement à ceux plus
largement on our le plus le rapport
entre l'offre et la demande
il est fort et donc le mois on aura
peut-être parce qu'aujourd'hui on a créé
tout seul un schéma de pertes et des
semblement le mot de la fin pour vous
laurent alexandre les 600 millions de
doses livrées de father en europe harlan
enseigne
il ya deux jours est ce que ça va nous
nous sauver quand même une lueur
d'espoir oui on va s'en sortir mais avec
beaucoup de retard et moi je fais partie
des gens qui sont scandalisés par ce
waterloo vaccinale il faudra une enquête
il faudra à comprendre pourquoi l'union
européenne ici à supplanter dans les
contrats à quel point la mails apprécier
la réalité du marché vaccinale et de
l'organisation de la production de
vaccins l'europe prend des mois de
retard à cause de cette énorme plantage
l'union européenne cela ne peut pas
rester impuni
merci à tous les deux laurent alexandre
jean philippe dugoin clément d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir est toujours sur le front du coc
vide en suisse cette fois la réouverture
des terrasses des bars et des
restaurants et effectif comme celle des
établissements de loisirs de culture et
d'installations sportives pas un signal
pour se relâcher alerte les autorités
alors que la situation sanitaire dans le
pays reste fragile
laure wagner avec pierre qui sévit vers
nous
quatre mois après la fermeture des
terrasses c'est presque un retour au
monde d'avant ce lundi à genève les bars
et les restaurants sont autorisés à
rouvrir leur espace extérieur tout en
adoptant un protocole sanitaire stricte
pas plus de quatre par table être séparé
chez d'un mètre et demi des nouvelles
règles qui semble convenir aux clients
devant les gens en terrasse même sens y
être alors y être son camp mieux mais
vraiment de voir les gens en terrasse
qui rigole qui excuserait plaisir ça
fait plaisir de revoir des gens un peu
un semblant de vie qui reprend
samba et ça devenait longue
c'est même plus
dans l'isolément puisque
une décision prise par le gouvernement
suisse alors que le nombre de cas de
kovy 19 est en hausse dans le pays
le but soutenir l'économie nationale
durement touchées en cette période de
pandémie
les professionnels eux sont heureux de
retrouver leurs clients bah c'est
incroyable comment courir et centre
heureux d'être là il faut bosser le
soleil la réouverture pour nous c'était
vraiment important de retravailler aussi
dans les bars parce que c'est super
compliqué comme hautement avec près de
2000 cas quotidiens en moyenne le
gouvernement suisse appelle tout de même
au civisme de ses citoyens
si comme dans de nombreux pays la suisse
mission la vaccination pour un retour
rapide à la normale elle n'exclut pas
non plus un rond confinement en cas de
forte hausse des contaminations
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'allemagne 1,5 mois
des législatives la droite allemande a
choisi son candidat non sans mal pour
remplacer angela merkel et puis nous
évoquons la mort du président tchadien
idriss déby lors de combats dans le nord
du pays au lendemain de sa réélection
pour un 6ème mandat
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début c'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
étaient à risque ou de ce qu'ils
pouvaient supporter il ya énormément de
problèmes en france comment se fait-il
qu'on est les impôts les plus élevés
d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés et c'est impossible
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il mis
en lumière lippert mondialisation et les
contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vie il ya une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut relocaliser bien il
faut déjà hors empêcher les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas alors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative on
sort du pic
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droite on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir amitié
[Musique]
oh
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous imposer
comme un espoir français du tennis
fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis et
que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec le genre d'homme en avait
un autre combat ma vie qui est celui de
la sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet
de loi qui vise à mettre en place des
tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
20h03 heures françois soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez la droite allemande
a choisi de successeur d'un gayda merkel
armin l'arche est sera le candidat de la
td ou à la chancellerie lors des
élections législatives de septembre
un choix au terme d'une lutte interne
acharné qui pourrait affaiblir les
conservateurs à quelques semaines du
début de la campagne
robin pu l
c'est une victoire qui pourrait laisser
des traces après plus de six heures de
réunion virtuelle le comité exécutif du
parti chrétien démocrate a désigné armes
ils achètent comme le candidat
conservateur à la chancellerie lors des
élections législatives déjà élu
président de la cds ou en janvier il
tentera donc de succéder à angela merkel
à la tête du gouvernement fédéral
allemand
ce mardi son adversaire marcus hodder
champion de la cs ou l'alter ego
bavarois de la cdu ou a reconnu sa
défaite
mettant fin à plusieurs jours de lutte
interne armin laschet tu appelle
maintenant à l'unité au sein du
mouvement
ce qui compte désormais c'est de savoir
quel parti a les meilleurs concepts pour
l'avenir de notre pays et qu'ils forment
la meilleure équipe pour relever nos
différents défis c'est pourquoi il est
maintenant important pour l'union cédé
au cs ou d'entrer dans la campagne
électorale comme une équipe
la cds ou ne gagnera pas cette élection
sans lacets est souffre et inversement
les ténors du parti ont préféré soutenir
le centriste l'achète qui entend
s'inscrire en héritier direct de la
ligne modérée européenne dans gala
merkel pourtant face à lui marcus odeurs
semblait être le candidat de droite avec
la meilleure cote de popularité dans les
sondages en vue des législatives de
septembre
un choix qui pourrait menacer l'alliance
cd ou ts ou déjà fragilisé par la
politique d'accueil des migrants mise en
oeuvre par angela merkel depuis 2015 une
division que l'opposition ne se prive
pas de souligner l'achète et ceux d'air
ne s'intéresse qu'au pouvoir ils sont
passés à côté des vrais enjeux
surtout à un moment où le pays est aux
prises avec la pandémie leur différend
était irresponsable et non professionnel
la lutte pour le pouvoir laisse une
union déchiré et de profondes blessures
face à des conservateurs diviser les
verts qui les talonne dans les
intentions de vote s'impose comme l'art
adversaire principal
les écologistes ont eux affiché leur
unité à travers un processus de
désignation harmonieux
c'est leur co présidente anna lena
bareback qui a été choisi pour se lancer
à la conquête de la chancellerie
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois pour les métis journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe bonsoir françois
pour les maîtrise merci d'être avec nous
en duel fratricide donc un pour un
candidat moins populaire faut bien le
dire que marcus soeder l'affrontement va
t-il laissé des traces qui aimait
blement surtout c'est un candidat qui
est assez atypique qui n'est pas tout à
fait dans la ligne habituelle d'un parti
aussi traditionnel que la cd ou c'est un
journaliste d'origine c'est quelqu'un
qui est venu un petit peu sur le tard
sous tu il est vrai par angela merkel et
qui avait soutenu en gala merkel sur sa
politique en matière en faveur des
immigrants ça c'est très important pour
comprendre qu'il a un petit peu une
certaine forme d'opposition à
l'intérieur d'une partie des cadres de
la population du parti de manière
générale qui considèrent qu'ils n'ont
qu'un petit peu de stabilité qu'il est
peut-être pas suffisamment convaincants
comme pouvait l'être par exemple marcus
slaughter qui est le patron de la
bavière qui est un land extrêmement
important et qu'il y avait une forme de
popularité beaucoup plus grande
mais je crois que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on connaît le
casting de l'élection qui va avoir lieu
en septembre
c'est à dire qu'on connaît les deux
personnalités qui vont pouvoir
l'une ou l'autre devenir chancelier
d'allemagne fédérale après après angela
merkel
et ça c'est très important parce que
d'une part la cd ou qui part en ordre
dispersé avec une certaine forme de
division va avoir en face d'elle un
parti qui est complètement unifiée qui
est le parti des verts est un parti qui
a su mettre à sa tête une personnalité
je pense par exemple qu'en france on
n'aime pas beaucoup les têtes qui
dépassent yannick jadot en sait quelque
chose
mais en allemagne celle inverse en
allemagne les verts ont su pratiquer une
véritable démocratie dans lequel émane
une personnalité qui elle n'est
absolument pas contesté et donc on peut
considérer que d'aller la berd
on a de grandes chances effectivement
peut-être pas d'arriver à la gent celi
mais d'arrivée certainement deuxième
position aujourd'hui clairement cet
ancien de championne de trampoline il
faut le préciser est ce qu elle a tout
de même autant de sens aujourd'hui que
son futur adversaire conservateur un peu
moins de chance c'est vrai parce que les
sondages récents la met en deuxième
position et on voit encore mal ça serait
une véritable révolution dire s'il
allait vers arrivée en tête mais si les
divisions qui sont au sein de la cd ou
cs ou se renforcent et si les rancoeurs
sur renforce effectivement toutes les
chansons là parce que davantage dans l
ena berlocq
c'est que c'est une femme qui a de la
personnalité qui sait ce qu'elle veut et
qui est soutenu en plus partout son
parti qui fait un seul bloc ce qui n'est
pas le cas en france puis en allemagne
c'est une réalité et donc la possibilité
d'avoir une chancelière verte en
allemagne n'est pas tout à fait exclue
d'autant plus que même si elle arrivait
en seconde position de manière assez
serré elle pourrait très bien constituer
une coalition avec le spd et les
libéraux pour effectivement devenir
chancelier donc cette possibilité il
existe la relève d'un gala merkel on
imagine 16 ans au pouvoir va être
difficile quel que soit le nouvel élu
qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir peser dans le
sens du futur candidat
bon je crois que toute façon de les deux
candidats ces deux personnalités sont
toutes les deux des personnalités
centristes donc modérée inverse modérée
d'un côté et un conservateur modéré de
l'autre dans les deux cas il s'agit de
candidats qui sont profondément
européens se sont dits candidats qui
pigent suivront qui ont probablement la
politique existante européenne d'amitié
avec la france notamment
mais des candidats par exemple comme
maddalena bareback elle remettrait
directement en cause le fameux gazoduc
north stream qui est directement en
cours d'année par une partie des
allemands
mais l'autre armin laschet tu es
quelqu'un qui est tout à fait dans une
tradition sociale démocrate chrétienne
démocrate qu'on a l'habitude et le voir
mais peut-être avec un style différent
plus chaleureux et c'est ce style
chaleureux qui a fait qu'il a
probablement été mis sur orbite par
angela merkel mais le problème
maintenant c'est qu'il va falloir
convaincre l'opinion allemande car sa
popularité n'est pas encore affirmer en
allemagne sur quoi vont se jouer ces
législatives
on le sait comme en france il ya la
crise sanitaire qui est sûr dans tous
les esprits est sur toutes les lèvres
il ya d'autres thèmes qui vont
réellement pesé pour ces élections
oui bien sûr il ya des têtes de l'avenir
de l'énergie la vienne la politique
verte pour l'allemagne l'avenir
effectivement de des différentes
énergies vertes possible mais les
l'immigration bien sûr reste quand même
un dossier important
la politique générale économique reste
un dossier important mais ça ne pourra
pas changer de manière énorme par contre
un parti comme la cd ou risquent de
souffrir d'une certaine manière assez
une gravement
des menaces enfin des des réputations de
corruption qui a pu avoir lieu chez ces
femmes membres du parti de la cdo et ça
ça peut peser effectivement sur la cd ou
pour ces élections
mais d'un autre côté pour anna lena
berlocq
c'est un parti vert qui est modéré je le
disais bien et donc qui est tout à fait
dans une optique de compromis et non pas
dans une optique idéologique que je
dirais et donc ça c'est un élément neuf
qui il va militer en faveur
effectivement dû possibilité de
compromis et surtout de coalition parce
qu'il faut pas l'oublier
en allemagne ce sont en général les
coalitions qui arrivent au pouvoir
et ce n'est pas forcément un parti des
coalitions donc le sens de compromis est
important et effectivement françois pour
les métis il est important de préciser
pour ceux qui l'ignoreraient que les
verts allemands ne sont pas du tout les
verts français exactement on aime on
n'aime pas les têtes qui dépassent en
france mais en allemagne on aime les
têtes qui dépassent et merci françois
paul et mathis d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir évoqué dans cette situation
après l'investiture donc d'armes in
l'achète pour la td ou pour les
prochaines législatives allemandes merci
à vous la crise diplomatique entre la
russie et la république tchèque touche
les échanges entre les deux pays de
gouvernement tchèque exclu de l'appel
d'offres pour la centrale nucléaire de
du covan y une société russe frag qui a
aussi annoncé d'expulsion de 18
diplomate en réponse un sabotage imputés
à des agents russes
elle a demandé cet après midi à ses
alliés de l'ue et de l'otan de faire de
même en retour moscou expulsé 20
diplomate tchèque moscou où l'on
retrouve notre correspondant antoine
clairon la russie a pris acte des
décisions de la république tchèque des
décisions lourdes en conséquence
diplomatique politique est également
économique en effet l'entreprise russe
rosatom a été exclu d'un appel d'offres
dans le secteur du nucléaire la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe de son
côté trouve bizarre quand cette année d'
enquête rien n'ait été trouvée et que
tout d'un coup de nos russes
apparaissent soudainement il y a eu
enquête il mener une investigation
cela a duré sept ans et cela n'aboutit à
rien il avait besoin de présenter
quelque chose au public
et alors ils ont trouvé petrov et
botcharov est ce une on est tous oui
c'est une honte est une insulte aux
citoyens tchèques sans aucun doute mais
apparemment il n'avait pas d'autre
option
derrière eux se trouvent les états unis
qui doivent poursuivre leurs propres
projets programmes et objectifs
géopolitiques
tous convergent en un point on l'a
entendu la russie estime que washington
se trouve derrière cette affaire est le
porte parole du kremlin ne dit pas autre
chose et regrette que les relations
bilatérales entre la russie et la
république tchèque souffre ainsi de ces
nouvelles accusations sans fondement
première chose certes nous estimons que
ce comportement de la république tchèque
est tout à fait dénué de fondement
deuxième chose nous estimons qu'il est
destructeur pour les relations
bilatérales
bien évidemment nous sommes d'avis que
cette politique de prague est dépourvu
de bon sens tout cela a l'air de
tentatives de ressembler en prenant des
mesures imprévisible et agressive à
leurs aînés de l'autre côté de l'océan
on a cette impression et le langage du
ministère des affaires étrangères est
tout à fait approprié parce que cette
décision ces accusations non étayées et
dépourvue de fondement formulées par nos
adversaire tchèque sont de toute
évidence scandaleuse et ne peuvent être
ni comprise ni analysé outre le renvoi
de diplomate et l'exclusion de recettes
home prague a fait savoir qu'elle ne
ferait pas appel aux vaccins russe
spoutnik v et ce même si ce vaccin
venait à être acceptée venait à être
autorisé par les autorités sanitaires
européennes elle la france perd un ami
courageux avec la mort du président
tchadien idriss déby le message de
condoléances de l'elysée qui souligne
l'importance d'une transition pacifique
et exprime son ferme attachement la
stabilité du tchad idriss déby a été tué
dans des combats contre des rebelles qui
promettent ce soir de poursuivre
l'offensive et sera remplacé ces 18
prochains mois par un conseil militaire
dirigée par l'un de ses fils qui vient
de nommer 15 généraux avant des
élections démocratiques promet l'armée a
décrété un couvre-feu et la fermeture
des frontières sont des nationale et le
gouvernement ont été dissous au pouvoir
depuis 30 ans idriss déby venait tout
juste d'être reconduit un sixième mandat
amaya soubelet avec quentin mauclair
réélu le 11 avril dernier le président
tchadien idriss deby est décédé ce lundi
des suites de blessures reçues au front
idriss deby avait été touché ce week-end
alors qu'il commandait son armée dans
des combats contre des rebelles dans le
nord du pays
le dessin d'idriss deby a été
officialisée ce mardi midi par l'armée
le maréchal du tchad président de la
république chef de l'état chef suprême
des armées
idriss deby itno vient de donner son
dernier souffle en dépendant l'intégrité
territoriale sur le champ de bataille
c'est avec une profonde amertume que
nous annonçons au peuple tchadien
le décès ce mardi 20 avril 2021 du
maréchal du tchad idriss deby itno des
suites de ses blessures
offrant la mort d'idriss deby intervient
alors qu'il avait remporté sans surprise
l'élection présidentielle tchadienne
avec +2 79% des voix
le scrutin avait été boycotté par trois
de ses neuf concurrents souhaitant
dénoncer ainsi la répression des marches
pacifiques de l'opposition durant ces
derniers mois le 17 idriss déby ouvre
une période d'incertitudes dans le pays
l'assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
ont été dissous présidée par l'un des
fils du président défunt
un comité militaire a pris le pouvoir et
promet des élections démocratiques
après une période de transition de 18
mois écoles et administrations ont été
fermées et un couvre-feu a été décrété
l'armée a quant à elle était déployée à
djamena dell annonce du décès les
rebelles ont de leur côté annoncé qu'il
ne comptait pas stoppé leur attaque
lancée le 11 avril dernier à l'issue de
l'élection
nous rejetons catégoriquement la
transition nous comptons poursuivre
l'offensive le tchad n'est pas une
monarchie
il ne doit pas y avoir une dévolution de
père en fils ne troupes sont en route
vers n'djamena mais nous laissons 15 à
28 heures pour que les fils de débit
enterrent leurs pairs comme le veut la
tradition
si les rebelles se dirigent vers la
capitale de nouveaux affrontements
pourraient avoir lieu avec l'armée
tchadienne allié d'idriss deby est du
tchad dans la lutte antiterroriste
l'elysée a dans un communiqué souligné
l'importance d'une transition pacifique
dans le pays à la tête du tchad depuis
30 ans idriss déby allait entamer un
sixième mandat consécutif
les obsèques du président défunt se
dérouleront ce vendredi et pour en
parler nous sommes avec mahamat adamou
terre président du parti rassemblement
pour la démocratie et le progrès bonsoir
matters
terre merci d'être avec nous tout
d'abord votre réaction à ce décès
ressort plus d'avoir le bonsoir à vous
même je vous dirai tout de suite que
nous avons appris avec une très grande
tristesse le décès du président idriss
deby itno
en cette période de ramadan au tchad ce
soldat se fier soldat au destin
exceptionnel aura marqué de son
empreinte l'histoire l'histoire
tumultueuse de notre de notre pays
landreau hommage à la mémoire de ce
grand homme d'état qui a contribué
puissamment à la stabilité et à la
sécurité à la sécurité internationale
donc nous adressons nos condoléances les
plus émues à ta nation tchadienne tout
entier est ce qu'on en sait davantage
mais amateurs et aux terres sur les
circonstances de sa mort parce qu'il y
avait quelques versions qui ont différé
ces dernières heures
bien nous n'avons pas encore de
l'information exacte sur les
circonstances de sa mort mais nous
savons qu'il s'était déplacé
personnellement sur le terrain au milieu
de ses troupes pour faire face aux
forces adverses et qu'il a été donc aux
blessés à cette occasion
mais je ne saurai vous donner de détails
plus précis pour l'instant clairement
c'est quelque chose que vous redoutiez 7
disparition du président tchadien
évidemment c'est une disparition qui
laisse un grand vide
étant donnée la la la personnalité du
président idriss deby itno
vous savez que les les institutions de
la ivème république reposer entièrement
sur la personnalité du pays d'ans et
donc du coup sa disparition brusque qui
a surpris plus d'un et qui assure le
plus mais tout le monde laisse un grand
vide et en même temps ou curieux de tout
justement c'était ma prochaine question
c'est un couvre feu a été décrété les
frontières fermées sont six à assurera
l'intérim avant des élections dans 18
mois ce qu'on peut clairement craindre
qu'une forte instabilité s'empare du
pays
diagou nous restons toujours optimiste
préférant rester optimiste
en faisant appel à la capacité de
dialogue des cadets est à la sérénité de
tous ensemble c'est à dire toute la
classe politique et y
les canadiens font preuve de maturité
évidemment cette période complexe qui
s'ouvre pour être surmontées et
maintenant nous avait tant à dieu le
tout puissant tout en gardant la volonté
de dialoguer sérieusement dans le cadre
d'une tradition avec l'ensemble de la
classe politique
que sait-on justement sur son fils ma
bataille driss débit est ce qu'il va
poursuivre en attendant cette transition
sur la même ligne que son père est ce
qu'il pourrait lui succéder
durablement bien c'est à lui de vous de
vous répondre
pour les spas donc la classe politique
est devant un fait accompli beaucoup de
discussions vont certainement sans
gagner ça et là pour dessiner l'avenir
politique du théâtre
vous conviendrez avec moi que la
situation extrêmement complexe
bien sûr le connaissons office idriss la
matrice des 10 qui est général de corps
d'armée nous le connaissons moins
attaché politique ce n'est pas un homme
politique
il vient donc de prendre les choses en
main dans le vide et il appartient donc
à souris tu as bien un faible dans la
concertation de devenir dans la paix et
dans la sécurité
l'avenir de notre cher pays ma dernière
question l'elysée a regretté à la mort
d'un ami courageux on le sert le sel est
un fervent allié de la france dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme notamment son
décès compliquer les choses pour les
forces françaises
oui il était quand même l'un des piliers
l'un des piliers de la politique
sécuritaire internationale au sailhenc
ont voulu vous le savez et sa
disparition que tout de suite donc
inquiéter les partenaires mais là
également nous le restons optimistes
vous savez que le pays d'art et de débit
avec des qualités particulières dans le
domaine donc aux militaires c'était un
soldat et il s'est toujours senti bien
au coeur au milieu de ses amis et je
dirais que c'est surtout aux cages
hockey
à côté de ses amis de ses compagnons
d'armes qui l'a toujours l'ont trouvé sa
raison d'être et ballonnements sont des
faits également été là merci merci mama
thalla ou terre d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france pour évoquer le
décès d'idriss déby au tchad merci à
vous dans le reste de l'actualité au
mozambique situation humanitaire
inquiétant de nombreux habitants se sont
réfugiés dans des camps par peur des
attaques via liste dans le nord est du
pays de vingt mille personnes ont
notamment quitté une ville prisée par
les terroristes puis libérés par l'armée
les détails de médias ce qui fit palma
libérer des terroristes mais vidé d'une
partie de ses habitants depuis l'
attaque jadistes du 24 mars dernier près
de vingt mille personnes ont fui pour
regagner pemba un port situé à environ
200 km de la ville face à l'afflux de
déplacer les organisations humanitaires
tentent de s'organiser pour accueillir
les familles et le mastering mi temps
nous avons vu plusieurs familles
arrivées à pemba très traumatisée et
dans des situations difficiles
ces personnes sont en quelque sorte
séparés de leurs proches y compris des
enfants séparés de leurs parents
nous nous occupons de ce problème avec
d'autres organisations humanitaires et
le gouvernement pour trouver des
solutions pour eux c'était d un pantalon
jugé indécent selon le haut commissariat
des nations unies pour les réfugiés près
de sept cent mille personnes ont quitté
depuis 2010 est la province de cabo
delgado en proie à une insurrection
islamiste
des réfugiés qui vivent dans des
conditions souvent précaires mal à
s'incarner phase et mon coeur me dit de
ne pas aller n'importe où et d'attendre
mon mari comme mon mari sera là nous
saurons walt et jesse abbey road
voir mon jeu dans est fait comme jacquet
pessoa
nous sommes hébergés au centre avec de
nombreuses personnes et nous travaillons
dans différents groupes dans les
domaines de l'hygiène de la
communication et de la santé de l'eau
est également fournie pour se laver les
mains afin d'éviter que les enfants ne
tombent malades trop c'est aborder la
vallée banon invétéré dont et sa
pointure et un ca en quatre ans
l'insurrection armée jazzist au cabo
delgado a déjà fait près de 2600 morts
une situation qui pourrait déstabiliser
non seulement ce pays d'afrique australe
mais également toute une partie du
continent mais nous parlerons dans
quelques instants de la france qui
élargit encore un peu plus la
vaccination chauffard août et caissiers
éboueurs de plus de 50 50 sont éligibles
dès samedi puis nous évoquerons emmanuel
macron le déplacement hier du président
à montpellier sur le thème sécuritaire
semble bien marquer le début de son
entrée en campagne pour la
présidentielle
[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose de
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
et eric bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il tourner les
impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés que c'est impossible
bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe nous sommes chez
boxart y allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tomber ceux ci sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
enfin les français ne savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
ans et demi
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage à
très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station milliards ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi 20 avril
l'agencé européenne du médicament donne
son feu vert à johnson and johnson mais
juge que les caillots sanguins devraient
être ajoutés à ces effets secondaires en
france la perspective d'une réouverture
progressive me mets sur toutes les
lèvres alors que le variant indien
inquiète les scientifiques on en parlera
dans quelques instants
en déplacement hier à montpellier sur le
thème sécuritaire emmanuel macron semble
bien marquer le début son entrée en
campagne pour la présidentielle de 2000
l'opposition elle ne s'y trompent pas et
tire à boulet rouge sécurité mais aussi
laïcité des thèmes qui risque de devenir
majeur en attendant une sortie de crise
sanitaire ce sera l'objet de l'édito
d'alexis poulain dans quelques instants
le thème de la mixité relance la faveur
relancé à la faveur de ce bain de foule
du président hier à montpellier une mère
de famille a raconté au chef de l'état
que son fils lui avait demandé si le
prénom pierre existait encore en dehors
des livres
alors l'école de la république manque
t'elle de mixité et la mixité est elle
encore possible dans les quartiers
aujourd'hui ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face
aux etats unis joe biden évoque l'
angoisse de la famille de georges fly
dans l'étang du verdict
il estime que les preuves sont
accablantes donald trump lui de son côté
accordé hier une interview à la chaîne
fox news même s'il estime que la
prochaine élection présidentielle est
encore dans longtemps l'ancien président
américain a confié réfléchir
sérieusement à l'idée de se représenter
fin 2024
[Musique]
au début de la deuxième semaine de
vacances unifier la situation sanitaire
en france est donc toujours fragile avec
un niveau encore loin du pic de la
première vague en avril 2020 mais tout
de même un plateau haut les précisions
de katia technique une nouvelle
catégorie de salariés prioritaires
pourra se faire vacciner dès samedi
la liste a été dressée par la ministre
du travail elisabeth bornes avec les
partenaires sociaux
vingt métiers tels que les chauffeurs
routiers les éboueurs les caissiers de
supermarchés les agents de sécurité en
tout 400 mille travailleurs de plus de
55 ans et aujourd'hui tout le monde
avait les yeux rivés sur le verdict de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments au
sujet du vaccin johnson & johnson
lagence juge que la balance bénéfices
risques est en faveur du vaccin
il conviendra d'inscrire que les
caillots sanguins pourrait constituer un
effet secondaire très rare certes mais
préoccupant pour cette raison les
autorités sanitaires américaines avaient
il y a une semaine fait une pause avec
ce produit
en attendant d'y voir plus clair après
quelques incidents graves
la décision de l'agencé d'autant plus
attendu que la france compte bien sur ce
vaccin et sur l'astra zeneca et de john
seine pour atteindre les objectifs de la
campagne vaccinale objectif de 20
millions de personnes ayant reçu au
moins la première dose à la mi mai même
s'il astrazeneca ne jouit pas d'une
grande popularité auprès des aspirants
aux vaccins et des nouvelles du
déconfinement olivier ferrand a annoncé
que l'épidémie décroît sait il y a tout
de même 33 mille nouveaux cas chaque
jour pas de quoi se réjouir
il a évoqué l'idée d'un déconfinement
territoire par territoire
sans se prononcer davantage mais la
levée des restrictions sera effectuée en
fonction de la situation épidémique et
du taux de remplissage des hôpitaux mais
le gouvernement ne tiendra pas compte
des indicateurs de santé pour la
réouverture des établissements scolaires
les écoles du premier degré vont rouvrir
le 26 avril les collèges et les lycées
le 3 mai et cela suscite l'inquiétude
des parents qui savent que les
établissements scolaires sont un lieu
majeur de contamination mais
curieusement pas de nouveau protocole a
été annoncé à ses parents très inquiets
on est nouveau record de contamination
kobe 19 ans dans plus de 200 mille
nouveaux cas ont été enregistrés au
cours des dernières
vingt-quatre heures au coeur de toutes
les craintes le variant indien 103,40
été découvert au royaume uni le pays qui
a pris les mesures énergiques pour
tenter limiter les cas on fait le point
avec estelle farges
il est surnommé le double mutants par
les médias indiens
selon b 1 617 il est catégorisé varion
of interest par le site de break point
info double mutants car ce dernier
cumulerait une mutation semblable aux
vaillants californien et une autre
similaire aux variants sud africain et
brésilien
une mutation qui le rend plus contagieux
est une mutation qui le rendrait moins
accessibles au système immunitaire
c'est-à-dire à la protection vaccinale
ils représentent près de 55% des cas de
contamination
il s'agit de 55 % des nouveaux cas dans
l'état du maharashtra qui abrite
notamment bombay et la ville de nagpur
où a été découvert ce variant en octobre
dernier
b 1 617 serait donc responsable d'une
nouvelle vague de contamination dans le
sous continent
on ne sait pas grand chose sur ce
variant que ce soit au niveau de sa
dangerosité ou de sa résistance au
vaccin mais d'après les propos rapportés
par le huffington post il pourrait être
plus contagieux que le virus initiale au
niveau scientifique
ce variant soulève de nombreuses
interrogations on sait qu'il est associé
à l'explosion actuelle que subit l'inde
mais il est toujours compliqué de
distinguer causes et conséquences
toutefois certaines des mutations qu'il
porte ont été décrites dans d'autres
lignes et de variants et pourrait être
associé à une contagiosité plus élevés
voire un échauffement immunitaire face à
l'inquiétude que provoque ce variant
certains pays ont déjà pris des mesures
c'est le cas par exemple du royaume uni
qui interdit tout entrer sur son
territoire aux voyageurs en provenance
d'inde
sauf pour les résidents britanniques qui
devront tout de même se soustraire année
le mans obligatoire du côté de la france
si nous devons prendre une mesure sur
l'inde nous l'apprendrons a affirmé le
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes sur l'antenne de france info
à ce jour près de 200 cas de ce double
mutants ont déjà été répertoriés en
europe et pour en parler de ce variant
indien nous sommes avec philippe froguel
généticien professeur à l'impérial
collège de londres et l université lille
2 bonsoir philippe froguel merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france on va essayer de voile aveu
d'en savoir un peu plus sur ce variant
ce nouveau variant qui nous fait peur un
double mutants pourquoi le qualifier
ainsi
vous avez déjà expliqué ça très très
bien j'ai pas grand chose à dire de plus
c'est parce que les caractéristiques des
variants brésilien sud africain mais
aussi californien ils sont des variantes
qui sont plus contagieux et qui pourrait
entraîner une résistance à l'immunité
qu'est-ce que naturelle des gens qui ont
déjà fait la queue ville ou qui ont été
vaccinés et donc c'est pour ça que c'est
très inquiétant ce qui est affreux en
inde c'est la rapidité d'explosion des
nouveaux cas notamment à côté de bombay
puisque passé en très très peu de jours
à plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes qui ont été diagnostiqués
problème beaucoup plus une autre chose
droit qui m'a affolés et qui est mal
connue il ya eu un avion qui est parti
de bombay pour roncq où il ya il ya
quelques jours il a maintenant dix jours
et personne n'était positif au départ et
à l'arrivée
mais les chinois de hong kong sont
prudents ils ont mis en joue les 188
personnes les ont mis en quarantaine
pendant 12 jours et il y en a eu près de
la moitié de l'avion qui était positif
annoncé 12 jours on est vraiment dans
une situation de quelque chose d'hyper
contagieux qui peut peut-être apparaître
tardivement
déjà c'était un peu le cas pour le
variés anglais et si les français font
pas des choses sérieuses comme on le
fait en angleterre ça risque de
compromettre
bêtement le plan vaccinal et de
libération de confinement des présidents
matheron effectivement le royaume uni
vous faites bien de le souligner qui
restera un les vols en provenance du
pays à ses seuls résidents depuis le 19
avril
clairement ce qu'on semble le faire en
france imposé une quarantaine
ça n'est pas suffisant selon vous il
faut prendre des mesures drastiques
comme le font les britanniques
il faut vraiment vraiment très prudent
voire interdire les personnes qui
viennent d'inde soit directement soit
indirectement à regarder à qatar et
relais ria airways par exemple qu en
s'arrêtant à qatar ou via dubai et si
des personnes viennent notamment des
français et bien il faut il ya plein de
dhôtel vide à roissy et orly
il faut vraiment passer jours c'est chez
pearson les airs puisque et au moins 2 à
3 fois et ciseaux positif faire le
séquençage complet parce que il faut
vraiment être sûr qu'il s'agit d'un
nouveau variant nous on va le tester et
la semaine prochaine à reims non on sera
dans la fin de la semaine prochaine si
c'est déjà arrivé en france on a eu des
échantillons aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
va ce vendredi on saura c'est déjà
quelques-uns on va surveiller ça de très
près dans les hauts de france mais je
faut vraiment mettre en garde le
gouvernement hier j'ai prévenu olivier
veyrat qui avait l'air inquiet mais
c'est paris jusqu'à à limiter les
voyages venant d'inde
il faut bien comprendre que toute la
politique française vaccination
progressive à la vitesse où on peut et
de libération aux principes de la vie
économique et sociale elle va être
impossible si on a une arrivée des
variants d'abord brésilien et puis des
variants indien en france on va se
retrouver une situation qui sera
ingérable
justement le sac le séquençage on vous
en parlait le royaume uni on le sait le
pratiquent beaucoup on a quelques
faiblesses en france ça s'améliore note
de ce point de vue là non en fait ça
s'améliore port c'est un petit peu comme
la l'apc
exactement un an les services de
virologie laissant nationaux de
référence pasteur pense que ils disent
partout qui font vers en réalité on n'a
pas plus de deux à trois mille séquence
complète qui sont mises en débat deux
données sont pas analysés puisque mr de
la recherche me vidal n'a pas mis en
place des structures de recherche il
nous permettait de savoir quoi faire
notamment on voit avoir de nouveaux
vaccins ou vraiment de réagir mieux dans
ce cas on vous donner un exemple qui
date d'aujourd'hui est un ehpad d'un an
dans les hauts de france avec des
personnes coincées vacciner kaiser ils
sont quand même infecté
eh bien il ya deux semaines l' agence
régionale de santé a demandé d'envoyer
les gens et on positif à pasteur paris
ils n'ont jamais répondu et donc qu'il
nous apporte demain pour que moi ils me
fassent un travail qui aurait dû être
fait c'est pas normal ce genre de choses
et comme comme un tas d'autres
d'ailleurs mais malheureusement en ce
moment philippe froguel quand on vous
écoute et qu'on est un petit peu novice
qu'on n'est pas ce qu'anticipe comme
vous on se dit c'est quoi c'est la vie
normale d'un virus et variant qui
deviennent de plus en plus contagieux
qui deviennent de plus en plus dangereux
ou c'est spécifique à ce virus là le
commis de 19 et moi je suis un
généticien et comme tout généticien
connaissant la rn ça je sais c'est nous
tous mes collègues virologues pendant
près de neuf quand on dit vous inquiétez
pas ça va pas 8 et 6 à 8 c pas important
ça m'avait toujours un peu surpris et
l'os la sauver et là j'avais raison des
pessimistes et c'est pour ça que de
décembre je suis vraiment mobiliser
parce que il mute et dans des formes qui
sont plus dangereuses et comme en france
on a une circulation virale très très
important on a des risques important
d'avoir un virus français aussi aussi
dangereux que lol que l'indien et par la
vaccination est lente et bien on n'est
pas dans la civilisation britannique où
ils ont jugulé
allah le variés anglais et bravo et je
pense pas qu'ils vont réussir j'espère à
juguler l'indien à condition de ne pas
se retrouver effectivement avec des
variants indien qui les envahissent trop
puisqu'on a bien compris qu'il était
davantage résistant aux vaccins
semble-t-il
merci philippe froguel en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre précieuse analyse merci à vous
l'agencé européenne des médicaments a
validé ce mardi le vaccin de johnson and
johnson control kobe 19 tout en
confirmant l'existence d'effets
secondaires rares une décision attendue
par les états membres de l'ue eux pressé
de donner un coup de fouet alors
campagne de vaccination maxima vert
après une étude attentive des cas de
caillots sanguins associe un faible taux
de plaquettes sanguines détecté après
l'administration du vaccin de johnson
and johnson la conclusion du comité
d'évaluation des risques en
pharmacovigilance et qu'il y ait un lien
possible entre ces cas et les doses du
vaccin de johnson & johnson jackson
le comité des médicaments à usage humain
confirme que le rapport risque bénéfice
reste positif est que le vaccin de
johnson & johnson est efficace pour
prévenir toute contamination kovy 19
c'était un feu vert attendu dans toute
l'europe comme les vaccins de pfizer
moderna et astrazeneca avant lui l'
agence européenne des médicaments a
validé ce mardi l'efficacité de celui de
johnson & johnson
le régulateur européen confirme
cependant un lien possible entre le
vaccin et de rares effets secondaires
graves observés chez cette passion aux
etats unis une enquête poussée sur ces
cas et d'autres indices ont mené aux
conclusions suivantes les quais de
caillots sanguins sont très rares le
report les effets secondaires rapportés
concernent majoritairement des femmes de
moins de 60 ans et apparaissent dans les
trois semaines suivant l'injection offre
des vaccinés fille la haye m souhaite
continuer ses recherches tout en
informant les citoyens européens
une notice d'avertissement devra ainsi
accompagné le sérum et nous sommes
toujours en relation avec les autorités
est américaine mais nous n'avons décelé
aucun cas au sein de l'union européenne
ce sont des effets secondaires rares il
est donc d'autant plus important
d'informer les patients pour que ces
derniers on reconnaisse les symptômes et
demande le cas échéant l'aide d'un
spécialiste
ce vaccin ne requiert qu'une seule
injection son entrée sur le marché
européen permettrait donc d'accélérer
les campagnes de vaccination en
attendant l'avis de la m
le laboratoire avait suspendu ses
livraisons en europe
son pdg s'est dit prêt à les reprendre
dès que possible de 100 millions de
doses doivent partir pour l'union
européenne la norvège et l'islande
en france le ministère de la santé juge
ces deux indispensables pour atteindre
son objectif de 30 millions de primo
vacciner à la mi juin
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique le
vaccin johnson & johnson est toujours
suspendu
l'autorité américaine des médicaments
doit se prononcer vendredi sur la
reprise des injections
en france les policiers en colère ils
ont manifesté dans plusieurs villes ce
mardi mobilisation deux jours après le
verdict du procès des lichettes sion un
verdict qu'ils estiment trop clément il
dénonce l'équipement de huit prévenus
des cinq autres ont été condamnés à des
peines allant de six à dix huit années
prison devant le palais de justice de
paris sur l'île de la cité plusieurs
centaines d'entre eux se sont rassemblés
à la mi-journée assemblement qu'a subi
notre reporter thomas bonnin entre 150
et 250 policiers se sont rassemblés
devant le palais de justice de paris à
l'appel de plusieurs organisations
syndicales pour faire part de leur
mécontentement notamment après le procès
qui s'est déroulé ce week-end la cour
d'assises dès mineurs a condamné cinq
jeunes à des peines allant de 6 à 18 ans
de réclusion pour avoir brûlé des
policiers dans leur véhicule c'était à
viry-châtillon dans l'essonne en 2016
huit autres jeunes ont eu eux était
acquitté c'est un verdict qui ne passe
pas qui provoque est vraiment de colère
et si dans les rangs des policiers je
propose d'écouter quelques uns des
représentants syndicaux que nous avons
pu interroger avec baptiste gosselin le
symbole qu'est données d'une façon note
c'est le chaos le chaos aujourd'hui vous
interpeller des individus qu'on 20 25 30
antécédents digne du catalogue de la
redoute comme on dit si bien dans le
jargon et au final derrière vous allez
même pas en prison et encore vous
rigoler quand vous voyez un policier
parce que vous savez qui vous arrivera
rien donc ces individus n'ont pu noter
aucune notion la justice doit faire son
travail appelons un chat un chat il faut
qu'elle arrête d'être laxiste elle doit
sévèrement sanctionné et il n'y a que
comme ça qu'on rétablira la situation
nous demandons à ce que lorsque les
collègues sont victimes
il ya des juridictions spécialisées qui
se met en place pour ce genre d'affaires
pour juger ce genre d'affaires il faut
bien connaître le métier de policier
son quotidien ce qu'il vit donc voilà
nous demandons aussi de protection et
reconnaissance et j'en profite de votre
antenne aussi pour vous dire que nous
demandons aussi que des peines minimum
au moins soit immédiatement donné
lorsqu'on agresse un policier mes
collègues ne peuvent plus quand ils
contrôlent on les traite de raciste
quand ils subissent des violences
ils ont un ou deux jours d'itt et et
tout le monde s'en fout ils peuvent
poursuivre les gars ils sont insolvables
dans les cités on ne peut plus y rentrer
et on se fait laminer on a des blessés
tous les jours on a des morts mais on va
aller jusqu'où comme ça on va aller avec
un petit peu de saupoudrage peuvent être
sain camping flic si on est 50 mille
interpellé dégâts qu'on met dehors le
lendemain à quoi ça sert à quoi ça sert
d'avoir plus de bleu un mécontentement
qui vous l'aurez compris dépasse le
simple cadre de cette affaire de
viry-châtillon c'est plus généralement
une forme de sentiment d'impunité que
dénonce ici les policiers ils ont été
soutenus ce cet après midi par nicolas
dupont aignan le député de l'essonne
justement qui est venu donc apporté son
soutien je vous propose de l'écouter
j'ai été révoltée par cette décision de
justice qui n'appliquent pas la loi
libre aux juges de décider qui est
coupable ou pas ça ne me regarde pas en
revanche il ya une échelle des peines
il ya un code pénal et quand des juges
condamnent à six ans de prison à 18 ans
des personnes qui ont voulu brûler vif
des policiers et que le code pénal exige
au moins de 20 ans 30 ans la perpétuité
je dis pourquoi pourquoi quand on veut
brûler vif un policier on a une excuse
c'est insupportable et cela a des
conséquences incalculables sur la
sécurité de nos policiers qui sont en
danger maintenant les policiers
demandent donc des actes forts de la
part des pouvoirs publics
il ya notamment le beauvau de la
sécurité également la loi sécurité
globale qui sont censés être des
réponses de la part du gouvernement à
quelques unes des problématiques avec
aussi dix mille policiers qui devrait
être recruté jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat mais tout cela est parfois
jugée comme insuffisant et surtout trop
tardive par les policiers qui regrette
qu emmanuel macron phase de cette
thématique de la sécurité
un acte politique à un an de l'élection
présidentielle c'est un peu trop peu
trop tard pour un certain nombre de
policiers ici avec lesquels j'ai pu
échanger en déplacement hier à
montpellier sur le thème sécuritaire
emmanuel macron semble bien marquer le
début de son entrée en campagne pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 l'opposition
elle ne s'y trompent pas et tire à
boulet rouge sécurité mais aussi laïcité
thème qui risque de devenir majeur en
attendant une sortie crise sanitaire le
chef de l'état est attendu sur tous les
fronts
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain c'est notre rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis alors avec la séquence
sécurité de ce début de semaine peut-on
parler d'entrée en campagne officielle
presque pour emmanuel macron oui alors
on est habitué à l'hyperprésidence mais
c'est vrai que là on sent une sur
inflation de présence du président
partout il était sur le toit de notre
dame en ouvriers cordistes il était avec
les élèves de la quatrième c'est pas
loin pour comprendre que oui on pouvait
faire cours à distance ils étaient
pédopsychiatre et puis il était avec la
bac à montpellier pour dire que le
régalien c'est son affaire
il est partout tout le temps même sur
des chaînes étrangères a parlé en
anglais on le voit partout même si on
veut l'éviter et madame mal qu'on est en
campagne et ça se voit le problème c est
ce que ça peut marcher
on le voit avec ses syndicats policiers
qu'ils comprennent que c'est trop peu
trop tard que finalement l'autorité
n'est pas incarnée par ce jeune
président qui a eu du mal tout son
quinquennat à faire du régalien à faire
de la sécurité à faire finalement de la
république et donc il s'en piètre il se
prend les pieds dans le tapis
avec à la fois la sécurité en essayant
de faire du nicolas sarkozy mais très
mal un journal titrait le petit nicolas
on parlant d' emmanuel macron et puis de
faire aussi de la laïcité
et là encore c'est marlène schiappa qui
est choisi pour parler de la laïcité et
qui marche sur des oeufs en essayant de
manier un concept qu'elle ne comprend
pas forcément à la hauteur de ce qu'il
est c'est à dire qu'il est
consubstantiel de la république
et là on trompe vraiment dans quelque
chose de grave parce que emmanuel macron
est en train de politiser absolument
tout pour essayer de pouvoir se
représenter avec un bilan qu'il ne peut
pas présenter face aux français parce
que de tous les costumes qu'ils
endossent je vous ai parlé de cette
déguisement qui sont nombreux il y en a
un qu'il ne veut pas mettre ces
monsieurs cent mille morts sa gestion de
la crise sanitaire est calamiteuse et là
il veut tout faire pour la faire oublier
car effectivement et lexie vous parlions
tout d'abord on va prendre les choses
dans l'ordre la laïcité avec le
lancement de ce jour cette nouvelle
initiative vous
et de marlène schiappa de quoi donner
plus de gages régaliens oui exactement
c'est ce que je disais et on voit bien
qu'ils cherchent les thèmes où il va
pouvoir prendre de la hauteur
redevenir président parce que à chaque
sortie on a vu ces scènes où des gens
sans masque sans geste comptables
prennent des celle ci avec le président
mais on a aussi vu le hors champ où
beaucoup de personnes étaient là pour
lui et emmanuel macron pour le traiter
de tous les noms parfois avec beaucoup
d' insulte et donc il doit d'une
certaine façon se représidentialiser lui
qui a perdu beaucoup de terrain depuis
cette crise sanitaire on l'a traité
d'épidémiologistes on l'a traitée de
beaucoup de noms comme je le disais mais
il a montré finalement beaucoup de
communication est très peu d'efficacité
or ce qu'on attend d'un président c'est
un cap
c'est une organisation et c'est surtout
rassurer et protéger les français et on
al impression qu avec l allemagne ont
non seulement les français ne sont pas
protégés mais ils sont attaqués de
l'intérieur par une présidence
paranoïaque pris aux abois la preuve en
est c'est que depuis le 29 septembre
2020 le calendrier l'agenda de la
semaine du président n'est plus publié
n'est plus renvoyer aux journalistes
c'est une surprise
chaque jour on attend de savoir où il va
apparaître et comment il va faire pour
juguler cette crise sanitaire
or sur la crise sanitaire et on le voit
on en parlera bien sûr tout de suite
dans cet édito il se prend là encore les
pieds dans le tapis et sur la laïcité
j'attends de voir ce qu'il sortira des
états généraux de marlène schiappa mais
on voit bien qu'il ya déjà là un axe
fort politique de donner des gages à une
certain certain électorat de droite pour
dire 'attendez 2022 ne sera pas sans moi
vous verrez que je vais veux pouvoir me
représenter mais rien n'est moins sûr
compte tenu justement de ce bilan
sanitaire
oui justement septembre à ce bilan
sanitaire et la stratégie mis à mal
est-ce que c'est clairement le plus gros
risque aujourd'hui pour emmanuel macron
oui alors lui c'est tout pour le
minimiser pour le faire oublier pour
parler de tout sauf évidemment de
sanitaires et il demande du bleuet
davantage de bleu dix mille policiers à
la fin de son quinquennat
leblanc on l'a oublié le rouge tous les
morts également on l'a oublié
or c'est le drapeau français et là
qu'est ce qu'il fait et bien il
est en train de donner des bâtons pour
se faire battre avec ses dates données
pour le mois de mai pour la réouverture
en disant on la trame dia coûte que
coûte
y compris la réouverture des écoles même
si ça n'était relance ça ne tient pas et
là ça pourrait évidemment tout faire
capoter parce qu'on a vu déjà le
problème avec les vaccins
astrazeneca halle qui a été critiquée
johnson & johnson qui a été arrêté puis
relancé ses vaccins qui pose des
problèmes de santé on aimerait savoir
les français aimeraient savoir si le
bénéfice risque elle réellement en leur
faveur en fonction de la population à
laquelle ils appartiennent
et puis derrière l'idée que ce tunnel
n'en finit pas parce que variant brésil
certes
et puis maintenant le double mutants
indien qui viendrait par avion d'inde et
on entend clément bonin secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes dire que
oui peut-être qu'on prendra une décision
sur l'inde mais on verra parce que
évidemment avec l'un de ses plus
compliqué de manière diplomatique
on a des rapports de vente d'armes
notamment les rafales et d'autres choses
qui font qu'on ne peut pas couper les
vols aussi rapidement qu'on l'a fait
avec le brésil même si c'était très peu
rapide avec le brésil donc les variantes
sont en train de se répandre sur le
territoire national la france devient
une sorte de shaker à variant et là
c'est une question que posent certains
épidémiologistes 1 à des médias publics
en disant on se demande si aujourd'hui
la stratégie de l'exécutif c'est
vraiment de jubilé le virus ou bien
d'atteindre l'immunité de groupe à
n'importe quel prix au coin qu'il en
coûte or le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est beaucoup de vies c'est beaucoup de
souffrance et c'est pas les moyens
donnés aujourd'hui aux hôpitaux
or si emmanuel mac on veut se
représenter devant les français en 2022
il devra être celui qui aura réussi à
gérer cette crise sanitaire parce qu'il
s'est mis en avant depuis le début comme
l'épidémiologiste numéro un est là ce
qu'on voit c'est un échec flagrant de sa
politique depuis mars 2020 merci alexis
paulin d'avoir été avec nous restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du thème de la mixité relancé
à la faveur d'un mode full du président
hier à montpellier une mère de famille a
raconté au chef de l'état que son fils
lui avait demandé si le prénom pierre
exister en dehors des lits
et puis direction les états unis joe
biden évoque l' angoisse de la famille
de georges frêche dans la tente du
verdict le président estime que les
preuves sont accablantes
[Musique]
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec le jambon manger un autre combat on
ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu si vous nous rejoignez si
emmanuel macron en déplacement hier à
montpellier a voulu s'emparer de la
thématique sécuritaire à un an de la
présidentielle de 2000 22
c'est à la faveur d'un bain de foule
qu'un autre thème a été abordé celui de
la mixité
une mère de famille a interpellé le chef
de l'état pour lui expliquer que son
fils lui avait demandé si le prénom
pierre exister en dehors des livres
tous deux vivent dans le quartier de la
mosson où un point de lille a d'ailleurs
été démantelé en mars alors l'école de
la république manque t'elle de mixité la
mixité est elle encore possible dans les
quartiers c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir et pour en parler nous
sommes avec geneviève pezot historienne
spécialiste des questions liées à
l'éducation auteurs définie chez les
garçons l'apprentissage de la mixité aux
éditions vendémiaire à bonsoir je ne
vienne peseux merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france à vos côtés kevin
bossuet professeur d'histoire en
seine-saint-denis bonsoir kevin bossuet
merci à vous également la ministre de la
citoyenneté a expliqué ce matin chez nos
confrères de bfm que la mixité sociale
était inopérant dans de nombreux
quartiers populaires de france
est ce que cette mère a raison de dire
cela c'est un constat que que vous
partagez vous sur le terrain kevin
bossuet oui c'est évident c'est d'un
constat en effet que l'on partage en
effet quand on va dans certains
quartiers de certaines banlieues on se
rend compte en effet que dans les
établissements scolaires bons trous
évidemment des enfants issus du même
milieu social cela s'explique par
différentes manières ça s'explique tout
d'abord par le fait qu'il ya dans
certains quartiers d'edena si vous
voulez de pauvreté ou tout simplement
les gens les moins les plus riches
finalement son parti de ces quartiers
donc forcément ne fréquentent pas les
cartes des établissements scolaires de
ces quartiers et puis ça s'explique
aussi par une montée du commune
taris avec en effet de plus en plus de
gens qui fuient ces quartiers à cause
des problèmes d'islamisme à cause des
problèmes en effet de communautarisme
musulman tout ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on se retrouve avec une école à deux
vitesses avec dans certains quartiers en
effet des établissements scolaires on
trouve des catégories
socioprofessionnelles supérieures et
d'autres établissements scolaires on
trouve presque uniquement des catégories
sociales intérieures
ouais je ne vienne peser même constat
vous qui avez écrit un livre sur sur le
sujet il ya vraiment voilà déjà sur le
constatons simplement aucune mixité dans
certains quartiers aujourd'hui en france
oui mais là je voudrais peut-être
revenir sur la notion de mixité parce
que moi quand je travaille sur la mixité
en fait je travaille sur la mixité de ce
texte
et ça fait vraiment très peu de temps
que peu de temps oui c'est au début des
années 1990 seulement que l'on a utilisé
le substantif mixité qui lui même n'est
n'apparaît dans l'histoire et dans les
criques en 1956 dans les cahiers
pédagogiques
quand on parlait de mixité on parlait de
la mixité de sexe et dans les années 90
et bien en fait c'est le milieu
journalistique qui a utilisé ce terme
pour l'associer à la mixité sociale à la
mixité nique à la mixité géographie
c'est une notion qui est finalement très
flou et qu'ils méritent d'être
interrogés et d'ailleurs dans le système
de notre éducation nationale
on a oublié d'interroger cette notion de
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mixité ça
veut rien dire un mot très flou de la
mixité c'est un mélange comme un mixeur
1 et on espérait que ça serait de
l'homogénéité naturel que quand c'est
homogène et bien on arrive à de la
justice en arrive à de l'égalité on va
je trouvais de l' équilibre est en fait
cet équilibre il est pas naturel et la
mixité elle nécessite vraiment et à
l'orée de nécessité un véritable travail
de réflexion pour pouvoir éviter la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui
mais tant à l'école que dans le
le milieu dans le monde et dans la
société
et ça me semble important de revenir sur
cette idée mais qu'est ce que l'on
entend derrière le mot mixité casser le
jeu kevin postuler vous qui est
également professeur d'histoire je
rappelle que mal à peser et historienne
on a loupé le coche c'est intéressant
d'aller dans le fond parce que souvent
quand on aborde ce type de sujet on est
dans la réaction et pas vraiment dans
les recherches des causes très profonde
c'est important on a loupé le coche de
ne pas se poser la question qu'est ce
que cette mixité que venir la mixité
sociale
aujourd'hui oui on a évidemment loupé le
coche parce que généralement quand en
mixité sociale en les hommes en termes
économiques on raisonne en terme social
on s'interroge en effet sur la catégorie
sociale à laquelle appartient tel ou tel
enfant mais la vérité c'est que dans
certains quartiers de certaines
banlieues ce qui pose problème c'est le
mort de mixité culturelle parce qu en
effet une importance de l'islamisation
il ya une importance du communautarisme
musulman et finalement dans certains
quartiers il ya les français dits de
souche même si je n'aime pas
l'expression qui quitte ses quartiers
parce que forcément il son sujet par
exemple au racisme anti blanc il ya de
plus en plus de juifs également qu'ils
sont obligés de fuir ses quartiers tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont agressés
parce que tout simplement ils ne sont
pas en sécurité d'un historien qui
s'appelle georges bensoussan qui a
montré que 80 % des juifs et a été
obligé de fuir la seine saint denis
quand on regarde ceux qui sont restés en
seine-saint-denis finalement on se rend
compte que de plus en plus c'est
juliette ont été obligés d'aller dans
les établissements privés tout
simplement parce qu'ils ne trouvent plus
leur place au sein de l'école de la
république à une environ une dizaine
d'années en effet il y avait trois
écoles juives privé en seine saint denis
aujourd'hui il y en a huit donc vous
voyez la mixité sociale ce n'est pas que
social c'est aussi culturel et ce qui
pose problème en effet c'est que la
république n'arrive plus à assimiler sa
diversité
on se retrouve si vous voulez avec des
quartiers qui sont des quartiers ghettos
où finalement l'égalité des chances
n'existe plus elle geneviève peseux
quand on entend le diagnostic art de
kevin bossuet qui est je le précise il
le rappelle est professeur d'histoire en
seine saint denis qui constate selon lui
en tout cas ce genre de phénomène
nouveau
dites quoi on aurait voilà dû
s'interroger sur des notions de mixité
qui qu'est ce que ça aurait changé
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dû faire de
différent pour éviter le délire c'est
amusant dans vous entendant parce que le
thème mixité le substantif il ne se
traduit pas en anglais on est obligé de
passer par le mot diversité pour
travailler sur ces questions ces
questions de mélange entre cultures
différentes qui qui vivent ensemble dans
les mêmes lieux
alors je crois vraiment qu'en sais tu ce
questionnement qui naquit arrive trop
tard peut-être puisque il
il émerge aujourd'hui en effet ça
n'empêche pas que certains ont beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions là dans les
années 90 et 2000 mais n'ont pas été
forcément entendu ces questions là elles
elles vont passer quand on parle de
mixité culturelle qui on veut une mixité
ça passe évidemment par l'éducation
il n'y avait pas les générations des
parents des adultes des personnes qui
sont arrivés au cours de leur vie en
france qui vont être en capacité de
rentrer dans une forme d'intégration
parce que finalement c'est l'idée
derrière c'est que s'il y avait eu un
bon mélange entre les populations ont
réussi rey a aussi intégré toutes les
populations elle se sentirait est
accueilli et elle pourrait jouer le jeu
de cette et inventer une société qui vit
correctement ensemble parce que c'est le
bien vivre ensemble qui est à nouveau
interrogé avec cette notion de de
mélange 2d alors des personnes qui
viennent d'ailleurs ou qui sont d'une
culture qui n'est pas comme vous disiez
originaire de la de la france
mais qui sont aussi des atouts
incroyable pour nous enrichir était là
où moi je pense que c'est pas trop tard
mais il faut prendre le taureau par les
cornes et de toute façon comme vous le
disiez une histoire récente fait que
comme on ne l'a pas bien anticipé
c'était une question d'aménagement du
territoire
aussi on a on a repoussé les les
familles les ouïes personnes qui se
ressemblent entre elles on les a on leur
a proposé de vivre dans les mêmes lieux
mais ça à partir d'un certain niveau
d'une certaine quantité de personnes on
se retrouve exclue ou n'appartenant pas
à ce groupe là est donc on s'en va et on
crée des des communautés alors la mère
de famille qui interpellait emmanuel
macron expliqué je cite que c'était
différent
à son époque c'est quelque chose en vous
est peut-être un peu trop jeune pour
l'avoir constaté kevin bossuet mais
peut-être le savez vous tout de même ce
phénomène de non mixité un non on n'est
pas fait quand on n'a pas de ce mot il
s'est accentué ces dernières années
c'est vrai qu'il s'est accentuée des
mêmes récemment les plus jeunes l'ont
peut-être constaté en d'ailleurs oui en
effet c'est un phénomène qui s'est
accéléré on voit bien en effet qu'on en
france une école qui est profondément
inégalitaire où finalement l'école est
le principal outil de la reproduction
sociale et donc ça forcément c'est dû au
fait qu'il ya un manque de missiles de
mixité sociale et le fait également en
effet que tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes chances dès le départ sinon
j'aimerais revenir sur ce qu'a dit votre
interlocutrice votre interlocutrice
parle notamment d'intégration mais il
est là le problème c'est finalement
c'est que le problème c'est que on a on
a voulu faire de l'intégration d'eds ce
qui est important c'est de faire de la
simulation le problème au sein de
l'école de la république c'est qu'il n'y
a plus de vivre ensemble c'est que les
jeunes ne partage plus les mêmes valeurs
et quand j'entends votre interlocutrice
nous dire que finalement on a parqué les
gens de même origine ethnique dans les
mêmes endroits c'est parfait c'est qu'au
départ il y avait une mixité sociale
sauf qu'avec
une montée du communautarisme musulman
avec une montée de l'islamisme est
forcément ceux qui pouvaient partir sont
profondément partie vous savez c'est ce
qu'a mis en avant le politiste laurent
bouvet qui parlait d'un sécurité
culturelle c'est vrai que pour une
partie de la population vivent sur des
territoires où finalement on a plus
l'impression d'être en france dès
forcément c'est excessivement compliqué
donc ces gens sont partis pour essayer
pour tout simplement aller ailleurs et
ce qu'il ya de dramatique finalement au
sein de l'école de la république c'est
cette école de la de vitesse et qu'on a
des parties du territoire français où on
peut convenablement enseigner les
programmes de l'éducation nationale il y
en ad'autres finalement ne peut plus
enseigner correctement les programmes de
l'éducation nationale on peut plus dans
certains quartiers ont signé là choix on
peut plus dans certains quartiers
enseigner d'égalité homme femme ne peut
plus dans certains cas leur qui est
enseigné notamment la reproduction
sexuelle tout simplement parce qu'il ya
une telle présence de l'islamisme qui
est telle présence de la religion
musulmane que finalement ça devient
compliqué pour les professeurs en effet
de faire leur travail je rappelle qu'il
ya un sondage qui est sorti il ya
quelques mois qui a montré qu'un
enseignant sur deux s'autocensurent donc
se quitter qu'on se retrouve avec sur
certaines parties du territoire une
école dans laquelle on peut enseigner
correctement les choses et de l'eau sur
d'autres parties du territoire pour
reprendre une expression de vincent
peillon alors qu'il était ministre de
l'éducation nationale finalement une
école où on ne peut plus enseigner tout
ce que l'on veut enseigner c'est ça qui
est dommage
alors pour compéter à votre propos je
voudrais vous faire écouter et robert
ménard maire est reine de béziers sur
son diagnostic
lauzon la seule vraie question pourquoi
tant de pierre ne veulent pas vivre avec
autant de mohamed de plus en plus de
parents musulmans envoient leurs enfants
dans les écoles privées catholiques
tout le monde fuit ces écoles sont
pierre la réalité c'est que la plupart
des pierres ne veulent plus fréquenté
ces écoles et leur part ont encore mon
jeu 9e 11e c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de répondre et vous les avez
vous qui avez étudié longuement sur ces
questions les réponses à ces questions
que pose le maire de béziers et aussi
kevin bossuet dans un sens ce qu'il y a
un problème tout simplement voilà de
religion de communautarisme et c'est
tout simplement ça qui a fait fuir aussi
les autres personnes alors j'ai très
envie de reprendre la parole bac je
pense que là on est dans un discours pré
polémiste qui fait que remonter
là la mayonnaise on est à la limite mais
qui est réelle en france aujourd'hui qui
est responsable d'une unité et qu'il ne
faut pas éluder
non mais au contraire et il faut le
prendre à bras le corps mais je pense
qu'on pose la question d'une pas
correctement
déjà quand on parle d'assimilation
comment et pourquoi assimilé il faut
intégrer et que chacun et chacune trouve
avec ce qu'il a en elle et en lui donc
avec sa culture sa place et il y a eu
depuis trop longtemps
ce désir profond que on doit devenir
français tels que on imagine ce que doit
être un français était ça sans doute une
des grosses d'erreurs que l'on fait et
que l'on continue à faire les discours
de droite en france le cloud et les
discours de gauche ne sont pas assez
courageux pour prendre ce sujet
finalement à bras le coeur et à bras le
corps l'intégration c'est à la fois
respecter la culture de chacun et de
chacune et réussir à ce que on trouve sa
place et que l'on fabrique que l'on
arrive à réinventer une culture communes
dans lesquelles ils peuvent trouver leur
plaque
je pense que il y à un autre problème et
c'est là où c'est la grosse difficulté
pour les enseignants et les enseignantes
dans les dents les les cités et les
quartiers qui reçoivent des populations
qui viennent avec des cultures autres en
grand nombre c'est une question de masse
qui ce qui s'est créée
d'autant qu' il y à un courant et un
mouvement mais qui n'est pas français il
est international
c'est ce courant vers une islamisme et
islam qui n'est plus dans la tolérance
qui s'est figé dans des réactions
j'allais dire réactionnaire enfin dans
des positions intègre islam intégriste
gangréné une grande partie de cette
population parce qu' elle n'a pas trouvé
sa place correctement dans notre société
en développés ou en développement ou en
tout cas qui accueille des d'une
migraine l'immigration économique au
québec ce fait nos maux d'un pardonnez
moi parce qu'on a dit oui à l'issue
c'est très intéressant effectivement
j'aurais j'espère qu'on aura là
l'occasion de vous re est invité pour
développer ces thèmes effectivement
kevin bossuet le mot de la fin en
substance est ce que c'est la faute au
monde occidental qui n'a pas su bien
accueillir c'est différent de conclure
non mais on est ici dans le discours de
la gauche bien pensante qui a tué
l'école de la république parce que la
vérité on nie pas ici dans le reniement
des cultures d'origine évidemment qu'un
élève ou est fière de sa culture
d'origine me voit aussi ce français
madame je vous invite si vous voulez
dans une classe d'un collège ou d'un
lycée de seine-saint-denis et vous
verrez que vous voulez qu'ils ne se
sentent plus français qui disons
permanent nique la france je n'aime pas
la france et ça pose un problème quand
on est dans le reniement d'un pays qui
les a accueillis même d'un pays qui les
amenait donc à un moment il faut
réaffirmer la république il faut faire
en sorte de faire régner ses lois au
sein de ces cités parce que les élèves
de france quelle que soit leur origine
sociale quelles que soient leurs
origines ethniques ont le droit à la
même éducation et quand je vous entends
madame vous est symptomatique du mal
français et je me rends compte à quel
point la gauche de l'éducation est
l'ennemi des classes populaires et
l'ennemi en effet des élèves d'origine
immigrée c'est dramatique
ah oui mais là ça vaudrait le coup que
l'on aille plus loin et je trouve que
vous m'attaquez de façon un peu un peu
frontale
je respecte mais c'est même discours
j'attaque parce que ça fait des années
qu'on entend toujours le même discours
et votre discours également proposé que
vous propose tout simplement je propose
que l'on paye affirmé lois de la
république sur le terrain on lui contre
l'islamisme lutte contre le
communautarisme on fait en sorte que ces
gamins se sentent de nouveau français
qu'on recréer du vivre en syrie des
gauches donc vive l'école de la
république vive la méritocratie évident
l'assimilation merci vous avez eu
l'occasion d'exprimer en tout cas de
tous les deux votes votre point de vue
j'espère effectivement qu'on est un peu
sont atteints mais malheureusement on
arrivait à l'issue de ce débat qu'on a
déjà prolongé merci en tout cas tous les
deux geneviève un peu ce et et kevin
bossuet d'avoir été avec nous et on aura
l'occasion vous réinviter en tout cas
merci à vous aux etats unis le jury du
procès de la sphère des gens je flotte
est parvenu à un verdict et si on devait
en devez le connaître dans la seconde
vrai pardon le connaître dans la soirée
de son côté joe biden estime que les
preuves sont je cite accablantes contre
derek chauvine derek robin qui est jugez
vous le savez pour meurtre homicide
involontaire et violences volontaires
ayant entraîné la mort il risque 40 ans
de prison il a plaidé non coupable
valentin car après trois semaines
intenses
le juge peter k il a laissé les 12 jurés
se retirer avec une mission décider de
la culpabilité ou non de derrick
chauvine dans la mort de georges floyd
le procès s'est terminé ce lundi avec
les mêmes images dans boucle celle de
l'agonie de georges floyd sous le genou
de l'ex policier le 25 mai dernier
pour ce dernier jour l'accusation et la
défense sont à tour de rôle pris la
parole et pour le procureur la
culpabilité de derek chauvine ne fait
aucun doute
nous appelons la police lorsque nous
avons besoin d aide
et il a supplié monsieur l'agent les
derniers mots de georges floyd le 25 mai
2020 furent
il vous plaît je ne peux pas respirer et
il a dit ces mots à l'accusé jugé pour
homicide involontaire et violences
volontaires ayant entraîné la mort de
georges floyd derek chauvine n'a pas
souhaité témoigner pendant ces trois
semaines de procès mais la défense a
tout de même demandé l'acquittement
après une plaidoirie de plus de trois
heures pour elle la mort de l'homme de
46 ans peut avoir été causé par de
multiples facteurs comme la consommation
de drogue et l'état de son coeur
lorsque vous examiner l'ensemble des
preuves
ouah lorsque vous examinez la loi telle
qu'elle est écrite et que vous concluez
tout cela l'état échoué à apporter la
preuve au delà du doute raisonnable et
monsieur chauvine doit par conséquent
être déclaré non coupable de tous les
chefs d'accusation mais stéphane
présentes pour ce dernier jour du procès
la famille de georges floyd n'avait
qu'un seul message à faire passer
remercier tous ceux qui les ont soutenus
je voudrais remercier la communauté et
je voudrais remercier tous ceux qui dans
le monde entier sont solidaires avec
nous nous recevons tellement de messages
et nous vous en remercions
nous répondons autant que nous pouvons
merci à tous pour votre soutien dans le
monde entier c'est aux douze jurés que
revient désormais de décider si derek
chauvine est coupable ou non le délibéré
pourrait prendre plusieurs jours pour
arriver à une décision unanime sur
chacune des trois charges retenues
contre derek chauvine
s'il est reconnu coupable l'ex-policier
encourt jusqu'à 40 ans de prison
alors on l'a appris ce lundi
le policier décédé au lendemain de
l'assaut du capitole par des
manifestants pro trump pour mois de
janvier serait mort de causes naturelles
c'est ce qu'indique la conclusion du
rapport d'autopsié un rapport très
attendu puisque le décès de brian
cyclique a ému de nombreux américains
choqué par cette attaque du siège du
congrès sa dépouille avait d'ailleurs
été exposés au capitole un honneur
exceptionnel joe biden lui avaient rendu
hommage sur place
[Musique]
b
il
et
[Musique]
dre pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec caleb maupin
correspondant berthet aux etats unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir qu'elle est bon soir le policier
décédé au capitole une mort naturelle on
vient de le dire selon l'autopsié
est-ce que cela change quelque chose à
alain tac du capitole je ne le pense pas
les conséquences politiques de cet
événement du capitole le 6 janvier
restent les mêmes les images que le
public américain a vu à la télévision de
ce capital attaqué par des manifestants
le fait que le fameux été tué par balles
le fait qu'il y ait eu des
confrontations dans le bâtiment du
vandalisme
pour moi le sentiment du public
américain les conséquences de cet
événement ne changeront pas suite à ce
nouveau rapport de topsy quels mots par
vous restez avec nous puisque on va
aborder un autre thème un aux etats-unis
puisque donald tram ne s'avouent pas
vaincus l'ex président pourrait bien se
présenter à la prochaine présidentielle
américaine en 2024 j'y pense très
sérieusement c'est ce qu'il a déclaré
pendant une interview sur la chaîne fox
news c'est la première fois qu'il a
quitté la maison blanche pour laisser la
place à son successeur joe biden en
attendant le 45e président des états
unis dans le viseur de la justice de new
york elle le soupçonne de fraude fiscale
et bancaire également de pression sur
les responsables an des élections dans
l'état de géorgie écoutez je dis cela je
m'y intéresse très sérieusement plus que
sérieusement d'un point de vue légal
je ne veux vraiment pas en parler pour
le moment c'est un peu trop tôt on vous
retrouve dans un entretien qu'il
envisage sérieusement de se représenter
en 2024 mais je cite que d'un point de
vue légal
c'est trop tôt
que veut-il dire il fait allusion à ces
affaires justement judiciaire lorsque
donald trump parle de l'aspect les gaz
de son annonce
il a par là aux lois de financement des
campagnes avant qu il est créé un comité
de campagne avant d'avoir organisé tout
le système de de réception des dons de
campagne il serait en violation du droit
américain
donc il doit commencer par organiser son
système organisé la collecte de fonds de
campagne avant que cela il ne peut pas
déclarer sa candidature
l'argent est très importante pour les
élections américaines en règle générale
c'est le candidat qui a récolté le plus
de fonds qui gagne il y à des
contributions directement pour le
candidat mais également pour les comités
d'action politique qui sont beaucoup
moins transparents et je pense que
donald trump n'annonce pas sa
candidature car il ne peut pas encore
commencer les levées de fonds donald
trump qui a même insinué qu'il y penser
comment cette annonce en tout cas de j'y
pense a été accueilli aussi bien par les
républicains que par les américains en
général
se retrouve chez public tient c'est un
néoconservatisme développe dès lors de
la dernière guerre froide avec le
président reagan et insulté lors de la
présidence bush
et bien cette vision est venu éculés les
américains ne veulent plus en entendre
parler
cette idée que les états-unis sont le
meilleur pays qu'il suffit de les
ménagères et si on n'est pas content le
fonctionnent plus aujourd'hui car il ya
beaucoup de colère envers le
gouvernement et donald trump a modernisé
le conservatisme afin d'y incorporer la
frustration envers le gouvernement les
théories du complot qui sont le plus en
plus populaire à droite donc cette unité
oryx on marche bien et tournoi donald
trump est le meilleur espoir des
républicains
merci canada un mot pas un correspondant
aux vertes et aux etats unis d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir et c'est la fin de cette émission
dont quelques instants point complet sur
l'actualité avec emilie gogh achats
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]